The graph below shows the
depreciation of a motorcycle's
value over time.
And they shows us the graph
and they say during which
two-year span does the most
rapid-- let me underline
that-- the most rapid
depreciation occur.
So depreciation just means
loss in value.
And this shows the motorcycle's
value.
You can just eyeball
this here.
Let's just look at what
this chart's saying.
This is saying right when the
motorcycle is brand new, when
it's zero days old, zero
years old, I should
say, it is worth $10,000.
And then when it's one year old,
it's looks like it's a
little over $6,000.
And when it's two years
old, it looks
like it's about $5,000.
Then at three years,
it's about $4,000.
And so on and so forth.
So this curve shows how
it depreciates, how
it loses its value.
And they're saying when
is the most rapid
depreciation occurring?
And they don't want to know
what year, they want a
two-year span when we have the
most rapid depreciation.
Now, one thing you can look at
here, you can just kind of
eyeball it.
You could say, look, the
beginning of this curve is
this steepest part.
It's steepest over these two
years than over any other
two-year period.
Out here, it's kind of a very
shallow-- it's almost flat in
terms of how quickly it's losing
value, so it's not
losing value too quickly.
So if you just eyeballed it, you
would just say, well, the
most rapid depreciation is
occurring over the first two
years, from zero to two years
up to this point because you
can see the curve is getting
less and less steep the entire
time, but it's most steep over
those first two years.
Now, if you didn't want to just
eyeball it and really
verify that it loses the most
value over the first two years
than any other two-year
period, let's actually
calculate it.
So after from zero-- so let me
write two-year period and
let's write lost value, or we
could call it depreciation,
either way.
So from zero to two years, we
went from $10,000 to what
looks like about
$5,000, right?
That looks right at
about $5,000.
So we lost $5,000
of lost value.
Then if we go from one to three
years, what happened?
One to three years, that's the
other two-year period.
You go from one to three years,
we started at it looks
like about $6,100, maybe
$6,200 or so,
and we went to $4,000.
So we lost about $2,200, so
definitely less than what we
lost in the first two years.
Then if we look at the second
through the fourth year, we
went from about $5,000 to about
$4,000, so we lost about
$1,000 in value, maybe
a little less.
Yeah, that's about what we went
from years two to four,
about $5,000, or maybe a little
under $4,000, so I'll
give it a little bit more value,
so maybe it's like
$3,800 right there, so maybe
on the order of $1,200.
And then if you go from year
three to year five, we're
going from about $4,000 to looks
like about $3,600 if I
had to eyeball it, so it looks
like we lost about $400.
So if anything, as we go further
and further in time,
each two-year period we're
losing less value.
So then finally if we go from
four to six years, it looks
like we're at about $3,800 and
we end up at about-- I don't
know what this value
looks like.
It's about-- I would say it's
maybe $3,500 or maybe we're
going from $3,700.
We're losing about $300.
It's shallower than
it was before.
So the most rapid depreciation
occurs in the first two years.
And you didn't have to go
through this exercise.
You could have just looked at
the chart and said, hey, look
how steep it is the first two
years compared to all of the
years after that.